nouveauté caillou ss qui est extrêmement
importante et je vous conseille vraiment
devenir le faire lorsque vous tapez un
e-mail et vous l'envoyez soit ça exprès
vous ne pouviez pas annulé désormais
vous avez un certain temps avant qu'il
parte pour un doublé l'envoi regarder je
montre comment il faut faire vous venez
dans mail et dans mail vous allez tout
en bas et vous cliquez sur envoi délai
d'annulation de l'envoi il a vous avez
le choix entre aucun délai ce qui est
quand même très très bête 10 secondes
c'est pas mal vingt secondes 30 secondes
30 secondes si vous voulez vraiment
prendre votre temps je vous conseille de
venir activé au minimum 10 secondes
comme ça si vous avez envoyé un email
sans finir me taper pouvait venir annulé
et c'est extrêmement rassurant est-ce
que vous connaissiez cette nouveauté
2016 dites le moi dans les commentaires
et bien évidemment pour avoir toujours
plus d'astuces et tout savoir
l'achitecte vous invite à venir vous
abonner